over a year ago now James Cameron
admitted that he was considering a
Terminator reboot so where are we now
what will it look like and what are the
chances it can happen welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and move a
channel Terminator is one of the great
franchises of real Hollywood history
Terminator 2 is one of those rare
Beautiful Moments where the sequel is
actually better than the original and
the original's bloody
brilliant James Cameron we all know is
an absolute genius when it comes to
these big spectacular movies and they
are
Blockbusters but Blockbusters with real
heart intelligence and substance which
again is quite rare
so what is he actually planning for
Terminator 7 well in a couple of
interviews since that first announcement
back in November 2022 he has talked
about how this will be a potential
complete reboot we also know Arie will
not be returning yay I'm going to
actually tell you who I think should be
the new sort of Terminator and it's
obvious if you think about it but I'll
come back to that in a couple of
minutes James Cameron has already talk
about how this will be sort of AI again
but a sort of more modern telling of
artificial intelligence an updated
version of that sort of more in line
with what we are actually all
experiencing today with the rise of AI
in the real
world he actually actually said once or
twice he's taking his time with this
because he kind of wants to get a
feeling of how AI is going to actually
impact the real world over the next
couple of years and then to use that to
inform his new storyline so would this
be a complete
reboot well the way the Terminator
franchise works with all the time
traveling Etc it would actually be very
easy to create a complete reboot a
complete reimagining without actually
ignoring all of the previous iterations
of the Terminator we've kind of already
seen that a little bit where of the
history that we'd seen in the early
movies then kind of got changed by
events in the whatever movie was coming
along they would stop the rise of the
Machines and they would just rise up in
a different way instead so it is
possible that he could create something
that was actually respectful of what had
come before but at the same time
completely new this wouldn't necessarily
have to be a sort of hard reboot it
could just be something different now if
somebody's going to do that and think of
a way to do it I actually think James
Cameron is probably the person and he
clearly over many interviews shows his
love for this storyline now dark fate
didn't work now even though James
Cameron was involved as a producer for
Terminator dark fate it didn't work
there were lots of problems with that
movie if I'm honest and um even getting
the original characters back didn't save
it it cost about $200 million to make
and it did take about $260 million and
it came out in October 2019 once you
actually consider all the distribution
costs Etc the movie actually lost $1 120
million at the box office and even
though critics and audiences to be
honest agreed this was a much better
reiteration of Terminator than we' seen
in the last couple it was still not good
enough if you like the video and you
like getting exclusive news about the
biggest sci-fi projects in Hollywood
don't forget to like subscribe hit the
Bell notification and leave a comment it
really helps us with those pesky little
YouTube algorithms so the new Terminator
movie Terminator 7 would be a reboot it
would be a slate wiped clean it would be
James Cameron in control from the
beginning and no Arie to be honest is a
good thing Arnold schwarzeneger has
always stood Head and Shoulders above
the franchise he in lots of ways has
been big than the franchise and the
obsession about bringing him back for
virtually every Terminator movie really
has become a problem as he's got older
now they've used some very clever CGI
Etc to do some very clever moments in
the last couple of Terminator movies but
the fact that his character has
constantly returned particularly in the
last two has felt awkward it is time to
separate Arie from the Terminator
franchise now I know they tried this
before when they brought us Terminator
Salvation Christian Bale and Sam
Worthington really did give us something
very different in The Terminator
franchise and I actually have to say
that Terminator one and two aside
Terminator salvation for me is the best
of the Terminator movies I actually wish
we'd seen a bit more of that following
Terminator Salvation then we went back
into Terminator 5 and Arie was back and
to be honest it just f felt tired
Terminator Genesis really just
personified why Arie shouldn't have been
in these movies anymore and I'm really
surprised he came back for pigging
another one with Terminator six so who
do I think should be the new Terminator
because I think there's an actor out
there right now that just personifies
this character he walks like the
character he's pretty big he's pretty
strong and to be honest he would be a
terrifying Terminator te anything Allan
richson plays Reacher in the series
currently over on Amazon and to be
honest every time he walks into a room
and every time he throws a punch and
every time he does anything I keep
thinking God he looks like a Terminator
if actually in the third season of
Reacher if he gets like hit and you like
see and you see a flash of Steel
underneath I wouldn't be surprised I
just think he'd be abs absolutely
brilliant if they bring back this
franchise he is an actor whose star is
rising I actually think Jack Reacher
should spawn a couple of movies if
Amazon have got any sense they're
thinking about it and then I think this
actor will probably be looking for a big
movie role and why not as the Terminator
he would be absolutely perfect in my
opinion anyway but what are the problems
what is stopping the Terminator 7 from
happening well there's a couple for one
the rights of the Terminator is quite
complicated Warner Brothers have dip
their tow it Sony have and so is Disney
so who owns the rights to the Terminator
it's a little bit complicated the other
issue I don't know if you've noticed but
James Cameron's quite busy he's kind of
promised us I think it's about 23 Avatar
movies if I'm right you
know yeah at least 20 um I'm not tell I
think what is it five I don't know but
we're going to be getting that and those
movies are quite time consuming so even
though James Cameron is working on this
and he is potentially working on a
script now no Studio has actually
stepped up and no studio is willing to
actually try to figure out the rights
issues but it's James Cameron at the end
of the day after Avatar pretty much the
only movie since Amazon other than maybe
Barbie that's really had a massive
impact at the box office if he wants to
do this and he has a script I would say
it's almost certain to get made at some
point I think we're going to be seeing
Terminator at the cinema once again a
completely new version but with the
master at the helm now that will be
something I want to
see but guys get into the comments tell
me what you think is this one of those
franchises that deserve deserves another
go or actually is it had more than
enough chances we had a brilliant opener
and then an even better Sequel and then
we've had five movies of various levels
of disappointment has that really been
enough as it had enough of an
opportunity at the end of the day if you
give something enough chances and it
fails at some point you let it go right
or is this a franchise too big to fail
and at the end of the day if James
Cameron wants to do it surely he's earn
the right get into the comments and tell
me exactly what you think if you are new
to the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com citre where most of our new
videos do Premiere first and you get to
see them without the adverts you lucky
bunnies finally you can go to
c.co Dedicated website where we do
articles based on most of our videos and
we try to add a little bit more
information for you today just go check
it out as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next
time character has always sort of stood
big
and his character of The Terminator is
already
really his
character finally you can go to
c.o. which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and you get to see them
without the
[Music]
h